Hello Internet! Welcome to Film Theory,
the show that just found itself a new pet.
Awww just look at this guy. He's adorable.
I just want to give his little fleshy head
a pat and… Wait, what's that little guy?
What? You want everyone to subscribe? Oh,
come on now, guys. How can you say
no to this little face? By the way,
do you guys like protein? A nice steak that would
look great on a plate in a pie sewn into a dress.
Well do I have a surprise for you friends.
It is Meat Weekend loyal theorist. That's
right. It's our very first four way crossover
for the theory channels. And we all thought,
what is something that truly unites the worlds of
gaming, film, food and style? And then it hit us
in the face like a wet, sloppy slab of beef. Meat!
and thus Mystery Meat Weekend was born, baby. Yep,
over on Game Theory, you can see us cover the
latest round of Merge Mansion lore where Grandma
Ursula's filling her pies with some unconventional
choices of meat. I just hope that Pedro Pascal
makes it out alive. Meanwhile, over on Food
Theory, we're looking into the very real science
behind mammoth meat balls. Yep, you heard that one
right. Scientists have cloned the meat of extinct
Woolly mammoths, and the first thing that we humans
did, we decided to cook it up and put it in our
mouths. Sounds pretty darn accurate. Speaking of
putting things in our mouth holes, over on Style
Theory we're covering whether or not you could eat
Lady Gaga's infamous meat dress. Because if you
are what you eat, then why not eat what you wear?
Yeah, making a dress out of meat, that was pretty
darn weird, but not nearly as weird as what we're
about to cover here today on Film Theory. You see,
today we're talking about the strange,
thick, meaty world of Vita Carnis.
Yes, we here at Team Theorist are indeed a
bunch of mature adults. A ton of people were
recommending that we check this series out over
on our subreddit and in the comments on GTLive.
So if you ever have yourself a suggestion for
content like this that you want us to look at,
those are two great places to go make those
recommendations. And I am really glad that
you guys put this one on our radar. This is
an analog horror series that you can go watch
right now for free on YouTube.com, created
by artist and filmmaker Darian Quilloy.
But unlike pretty much all other analog horror
series Vita Carnis isn't leaning into uncanny
liminal strangeness like The Backrooms or weird
twisted doppelgangers like Mandela Catalog or
even nostalgic mascot horror like… pretty much
everything else. Instead, the creep factor here
is coming from horrifying creature design.
Vita Carnis is the story of weird meat based
creatures that have started appearing in nature.
And let me just say this one up front. This is
one of the most original analog horror series
that I've seen in a long time. The monsters
are made of flesh and eat bones, but they also
grow like plants. It’s a very cool idea. In the
series we learn most of our information through
documentary tapes filled with strange glitches.
But there's also archived home videos and
newspaper clippings thrown in for good measure.
And where there's creepy, hidden details, you know
that there's plenty of lore to decode. In short,
I devoured my time with Vita Carnis. And
let me tell you the deeper and deeper we
get into this documentary, the more pieces
of the puzzle that start falling into place.
Where is this mystery meat coming from? Why
is the government trying to cover it all up?
And is there anything that we can do to
stop what seems to be our inevitable trip
to the meat grinder? Season your food
and ready your Meat Snakes friends,
today we've got ourselves a lot to chew on.
So to start things off, what exactly is going
on? As I mentioned at the top of the theory,
the bulk of Vita Carnis’s story is told through
a documentary put together by the National
Living Meat Research to educate the public,
and by extension us, about the
creatures in this new genus of skinless
animals made out of muscle organs and bones.
They're called Vita Carnis, Latin for living meat.
And not only do they look like raw meat,
they also love to consume raw meat.
Obviously not a concern for all us fleshy
meat snacks out there. As the story goes,
these creatures basically appeared out of nowhere
starting in 1931, and their population quickly
skyrocketed over the subsequent decades.
The documentary is quick to point out that…
Seemingly ruling out that they're aliens or
demons or any other classic analog horror fare.
In fact, their taxonomy is really well laid out
across these videos. The Vita Carnis genus is
split into several species: some cute,
some useful, and some literal nightmare
fuel that will get you second guessing
your next hike out into nature. In fact,
the more we hear about each of these types
of critters, the more the dark truth of
this world starts coming into focus.
The first few creatures are weird,
but more or less benign. The most abundant of
these is known as The Crawl, which are these
sort of vines that resemble intestines growing
across the entire world. This stuff is edible and
apparently makes for a good meat substitute.
To the point that it's been domesticated and
used in several popular in-universe meals.
In fact, one of the videos on the channel
is a tutorial on how to create a
cheesy pasta dish using the crawl.
Watch out, boys. Looks like we have
ourselves another new entrant in the
Babish Culinary Universe. The second type
of creature is known as Trimmings. These
things grow from The Crawl, fall off, and
then start skittering around on their own.
They're basically sad little flesh
turtles that run, hide and scream.
Next up is my personal favorite
of the bunch, the Meat Snake.
Yeah, what can I say? I just love myself some
Meat Snake. According to the lore these things
are basically dead body garbage disposals,
crawling around and eating dead carcasses.
Animal or otherwise. And in what might be
one of the coolest bits of creature design
that I've seen from an analog horror series in
a while, they take the skulls of the creatures
they consume and then use them as their own.
Normally, these things are only supposed to grow
up to five meters or 16 feet, which is already
pretty darn long. But astute viewers can actually
find a hidden newspaper clipping that confirms
that they can grow to be much larger. After
World War II, a quote, “extremely engorged Meat
Snake of impeccable size.” Their words, not mine.
Was discovered in a tunnel underneath Germany,
which consumed so many dead bodies from the war
that it grew to eight times the average length.
The skin of this behemoth was also more powerful.
It was darker and harder than a normal Meat Snake.
I don't know how much of this is actual lore and
how much of this is just trolling. Anyway, the
scientists who found it had a lot of difficulty
cutting through the Meat Snake. And with that it's
here that the creatures of Vita Carnis take a hard
right turn away from weirdly cute with funny
names into pure, distilled nightmare fuel.
Next up, we got ourselves the Mimic, which are
exactly what they sound like. Humanoid creatures
with creepy smiles, bulging eyes, extended
limbs, and a diet composed of human flesh.
These puppies are fast, too. The more
humans they eat, the more human they look,
and the darker their skin becomes. That
last part sounds like a weird detail,
but now that's the second time
that we've heard it mentioned. So,
feels like an important detail to keep in the
back of our minds. Mimics will pick out a target,
use clothing to disguise themselves
or even go so far as to hide in the
furniture in an attempt to capture their prey.
Don't know how a tall, lanky flesh monster
is going to be hiding in the family bean bag
chair. But sure, we'll just go for it. And yet,
despite the massive threat that this thing
poses to humankind, it doesn't really seem
that there's all that much being done about
it. Sure. Apparently the world governments
have offered advice to their citizens, but
it all really amounts to “don't die lol”.
The horror only continues with the next creature
too called the Harvester. These are large masses
of flesh that plant themselves in the earth
and then extend roots out in all directions.
But unlike typical Crawl, these roots have
literal thorns in them that will stab into
any large animal that walks on them. The
worst part of all this, the thorns are
full of venom that disable the nervous system
and prevent a victim's blood from clotting,
which means that they're going to kill them
from blood loss so the body can then be
consumed. And if all of that wasn't bad enough,
there's apparently no way of surviving this.
We later see and hear what a death by harvester
is like in the video Species Anomaly Report.
And let me tell you, it is not pleasant.
Now, normally at this point in the script,
I'd insert a little clip here to help illustrate
my point. But let me tell you, it's rough,
even for me. Just take my word for it, it is
scary stuff, as if we needed more reasons to not
go and touch grass. And then we have what might
be the creepiest of these freak shows, the Host
of Influence. Creatures with semi humanoid torsos
and masses of vines that burrow into the ground.
Spines extend from their backs, releasing clouds
of orange spores that can infect other organisms.
From there, the spores go directly into the brain
and temporarily alter the minds of the victims,
compelling them to sacrifice
themselves to the host. Which,
yes, I too, have seen The Last of Us. Thank
you very much. Someone called Pedro Pascal.
Looks like we're going to need his help again.
Meat weekend? More like Pedro Pascal Weekend.
I Wonder if I could figure out a way to
work him into the meat dress episode.
If I did go down to the comments and say like,
“Hey, I understood that reference”. Just to show
everyone that you were here, that you have
officially completed the meat cycle. Anyway,
in the most recent video on the channel:
Message, we see a newspaper clipping that
says that the authorities are refusing to handle
any harvesters. Why? Are they scared? Is there
nothing they can do? No, I don't think so.
Remember how I just talked about the Hosts
releasing clouds of orange powder? Well, later
on on the channel there's that random cooking
upload that I made a joke about earlier. The
Cheesy Crawl Casserole. Well, in that video,
we watch as they use a special seasoning
called the Nutrire Co Flavor Enhancer,
a suspiciously orange powder.
Not only that, but the company's
logo is a black circle with a red triangle
in the middle. This exact series of shapes
flashes across the screen during a similar part
of the documentary, talking about the hosts.
See it right there for that single
frame? It’s the exact same logo. Clearly,
these two things are connected.
And just like with the spores,
the flavor enhancer is apparently something
that people at Nutrire Co don't want to be
inhaling for themselves. For a moment during
our cooking tutorial the faceless Babish cook
leans down and we get the briefest glimpse of
a gas mask covering his face. Something else
that lets you know that something's just
off about this powder. Notice what else
happens to the soothing guitar background
music when the flavor enhancer gets added.
The guitar gets crazy. It's
almost like the mind of the
player has been altered in some way.
And did you hear what she just said?
The enhancer doesn’t work if it's above 60 degrees
Celsius or 140 degrees Fahrenheit. Conveniently
enough, that's the exact temperature at which most
fungus dies, like we talked about in our Last of
Us video. Go figure. And as if you needed any more
proof, a newspaper clipping from Message reveals
that Nutrire Co is facing charges from people
getting sick after consuming their products.
So things are already looking pretty darn bad
for humanity. We've got meat vines everywhere,
humanoid mimics in our furniture, meat snakes in
our subways, poison in our powders, and even more
reasons to fear going out on hikes. But it's
here that once again, we reach a significant
change in tone, veering from analog horror spoops
to Lovecraftian SCP terror with the Monoliths.
These things appeared in 1972. Standing in a
perfect circle in a redacted location surrounding
something else that's been redacted.
Based on a map that we see in the video,
we can figure out that the location is on
an island in Canada's Hudson Bay. And given
that we see a map in another video named Message
saying that the Vita Carnis creatures all seem
to be moving to this location, this seems
to be the point of origin for everything.
So what exactly are these monoliths? Well,
they’re seven entities that are roughly the
size of a 37 story skyscraper. Their legs are
firmly rooted into the ground with dozens of long,
ropey tentacles that move about. Creepiest of
all, though, these things just kind of stand
around. They don't really react to anything.
At one point several military vehicles
attempted to bomb the monoliths, but they just
released an EMP pulse that disabled the attack.
Even the bombs that managed to hit didn't
do that much because the monoliths just
repaired themselves. However, did you notice
the important detail here? They released an
electromagnetic pulse to defend themselves. That
right there, that's weird. Throughout the series,
we see a lot of instances where the Vita
Carnis creatures seem to be taking control
of or just outright destroying technology.
During a glitch in the first documentary tape
we briefly see a newspaper clipping reporting
that a radio tower has become overgrown by the
Crawl. Other newspaper clippings report
Trimming infestations under satellite
dishes and still other videos point out their
interest in tech like television and radio.
It would appear as though the Carnis
are learning from this technology,
since we're told that these creatures are
closely connected to nature. It's likely that
they're latching onto these unnatural human
creations to either spy on us, destroy them,
or ultimately use them against us. Now, at first
glance, at the channel's uploads, that would seem
like the end of the main series releases.
Sure, there are some found footage videos
in the mix, the cooking tutorial, a commercial
for the seasoning powder, stuff like that. But
outside of a re-uploaded compilation of all the
previous videos, that seems to be the end of the
documentary segments that formed the foundation
of this world. Except that would be missing a
huge final reveal hiding in plain sight.
You see what at first appears to be a
rote re-upload of all the shorter documentary
segments put together actually contains a final,
all new monster, a creature that seems to be the
one behind all of Vita Carnis’s chaos. This thing
is known simply as The Singularity, and it's
completely unlike everything we've talked about
so far. It's a one meter in diameter dark
sphere that's floating off the ground.
That’s it, it's a big ol’ ball. We're told
that several strange magnetic fields and
energy signatures are coming out of
the singularity, but all the other
information about it is kept classified and the
government wants to keep it that way. You see,
according to a newspaper clipping that we see on
screen during the latest video Message, the people
at National Living Meat Research were arrested
for making this documentary because it included,
quote, sensitive materials and defamation.
But why? I mean, Mimics and Harvesters are
killing people en masse. Hosts are spewing out
mind altering spores. And there's a corporation
selling those spores as a spice to add to
our food. Something feels off here. I mean,
what is the government hiding? Well, as the man
uncovering the conspiracy in the video puts it.
And I suspect that the singularity is at the
center of it all, you see special reports
and newspaper clippings aren't the only thing
that's hidden under the surface of the series,
disguised in the glitches of these videos, we can
find pages from what appear to be a children's
storybook telling the story of a long lost prince.
Some parts of the pages are unreadable due to
either glitches covering up the text video
artifacting that blurs the letters or just
being cut off. But we can largely get the
gist of the story. So sit down and relax,
as I tell you, a dark, twisted tale. Once
upon a time, the magical royal family of a
distant kingdom wished to discover new lands.
But as they were traveling by sea, their ship
was struck by a giant storm. The prince fell
overboard, eventually washing up injured on an
island. He stumbles into a nearby cave using what
magic he can to put himself into a healing sleep.
He slumbered for a long time what seemed like
forever, long enough for the land around him to
change and evolve into something unrecognizable.
Outside of the cave, a group of small critters
began living on the island, struggling in
times of hardship when there was too little
food to go around. Eventually, the critters
found the sleeping prince awestruck by his
magic. Some of them wondered if they'd be
able to use the prince's magic to grow food
and heal sickness. But the majority agreed that
he was too dangerous and should be left alone.
Despite this, some critters ignored the decision,
sneaking what food they had to feed the prince,
hastening his recovery. Thanks to them, the
prince awoke and now fully recovered. The
prince befriended the critters. They formed
a bond with the critters leading the prince
to their home inside the forest. They asked
the prince if he would be able to help them,
since the forest was unable to provide
everything they needed to survive.
The prince agreed, using his magic
to summon mystical lights, shapes,
colors and figures. The critters were mesmerized
by the prince's brilliance, and they built the
Prince a raft so he could return to his home
kingdom. As he left, the Prince vowed that
with his power and the aid of the kingdom, he
would someday return and heal the critters' home.
While on the surface, this just seems to be like
an odd little side story, a series of Easter eggs
hidden in an analog horror video to add to the
mystery. It is far from that. The way I see it,
this is literally a metaphor for the entire
story that Vita Carnis is trying to tell us.
The Prince. That's the singularity or whatever
is at the center of all this mess in Canada,
controlling the rest of these
meek creatures around the world.
I suspect it's from some super powerful alien
civilization. While traveling the cosmos with
others of its kind, just like the prince on a
ship, it's hit by some sort of tragedy in space,
either a supernova or some sort of big
bang, something that is so powerful that
our pathetic little human meat brains
can't comprehend the scale. Either way,
this alien creature is separated from all the
others, and then it crash lands here on Earth
millions of years ago in what eventually becomes
modern day Hudson Bay. It's there in the Hudson
Bay that this alien entity forms an island that
exists in the world of Vita Carnis, but not in
our own world. Injured by the impact whatever this
creature is went into hibernation that has lasted
itself hundreds of millions, maybe even billions
of years, at least long enough that it seems that…
Tectonic activity and life on earth reshaped
the planet above it, just like the world outside
the Prince's cave changed while he was asleep.
Eventually, intelligent life formed on the planet:
us lowly humans. We're the critters from that
story, using up the resources of the world and
struggling to survive, at least in the eyes
of this more highly evolved being. Some humans
eventually find the entity in the 1930s, and
while most of the people in charge wanted to
leave the creature, others didn't.
They saw it as a way to progress,
to save themselves and the species from
dwindling resources on Earth as humanity
wrings it dry. And why wouldn't they? It's
this incredible Lovecraftian being beyond
anything we understand. And the organic material
he creates helps the natural life cycle of earth.
A cult forms in the highest rankings of
humanity; in governments and corporations
and militaries. All of them focused on somehow
resuscitating this mysterious being. See this
symbol on the flag that was put on the princess
raft that they rebuilt? It's the same symbol
that we see on the flavor enhancer. It's the
same thing that gets called out in multiple
other videos. It's the symbol that represents
whatever this cult worshiping the entity is.
And how do they plan on bringing it back?
Well, just like the prince in the story,
they start feeding the entity, they start
feeding it meat, specifically humans.
That's why nothing is being done about the
Mimic or Harvester attacks. That's why the
mind control spores are being distributed as
condiments. That's why people are encouraged
to eat the Crawl and pretend that everything
is okay and normal. That's why the elder Mimics
and the giant meat snake that they found in
the tunnel are so much more powerful than the
others. They've eaten more humans. They've
grown stronger and darker as a result. Not
quite as dark as the prince or the singularity,
a giant floating black ball. But both the Mimic
documentary and the Meat Snake archival video
make a specific point to call out the color.
And I've got to say, at this point, it
seems like the cult’s been successful,
given the explosive growth of the Vita Carnis
over the past century. So is that it for humanity?
Is the world doomed to fall to this Lovecraftian
alien being and the cult following it as it slowly
awakens from its slumber? Thankfully, not yet. The
latest video gives us hope, since it appears that
the people behind the Vita Carnis documentary
are connected to another organization that's
starting a resistance. Known as the Containment
and Research Consult Association Society or
C.A.R.C.A.S. for short. It's an acronym. We love
ourselves a good acronym. They've started their
own recruitment drive and are attempting to blow
this conspiracy wide open. Aaand that's about it,
actually. That's about as far as the story's
gotten at this point, let me tell you. I,
for one, cannot wait to see where this one goes
next. Like I said at the top of the episode,
this has been one of the most original analog
horror series I've watched in a while, and I
hope that us covering it here gets more eyeballs
over to Darian's hard work and spine chilling art.
But while this may be all that we have right
now for Vita Carnis, it is not all that we have
for Mystery Meat Weekend my friends. Remember
to go check out all the other videos at our
sister locations since we've been talking
about eating Vita Carnis in this episode,
might I recommend checking out what
we have cooking over on Food Theory?
You ever wonder what a mammoth meatball
tastes like? Well, I'm about to tell ya.
It is literally like we're living in Jurassic
Park. Let's just clone an extinct creature. But
instead of creating an amusement park, let's just
create an equivalent of a restaurant. Good job,
humans. That video is on screen right now, so
click it and enjoy all the savory goodness that is
Meat Week. As always my friends, if you're hungry
for more juicy content, click that subscribe
button across all our channels. And remember, it's
all just a theory. A FILM THEORY! aaaaaaand cut.